>>> IN OUR SERIES "MEDICAL PRICE
ROULETTE," WE'RE SHARING THE
STORY OF A YOUNG MAN WHO
SURVIVED MASSIVE INJURIES AND
MONTHS OF RECOVERY ONLY TO FACE
OVERWHELMING MEDICAL BILLS.
OUR CONSUMER INVESTIGATIVE
CORRESPONDENT, THERE SHE IS,
ANNA WERNER, JOINS US WITH MORE
ON HIS STORY.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING,
GAYLE.
AND YOU KNOW, THE TIP ON THIS
STORY ACTUALLY CAME FROM OUR OWN
DAVID BEGNAUD WHO ASKED ME IF I
COULD INVESTIGATE WHY THIS YOUNG
MAN FROM PUERTO RICO WHO HAD
REACHED OUT TO DAVID IN
DESPERATION BASICALLY WAS FACING
A STAGGERING BILL.
A BILL FOR INJURIES THAT NEARLY
KILLED HIM.
WE DO WANT TO MENTION, SOME
IMAGES MAY BE DISTURBING.
>> DOING GREAT --
>> Reporter: THIS IS HOW ALEXIS
HERNANDEZ MADE HIS WAY BACK FROM
THE ACCIDENT -- STEP BY LABORED
STEP, OVER THE SEVEN MONTHS AT A
TEXAS MILITARY HOSPITAL
RECOVERING FROM BURNS ALL OVER
HIS BODY.
>> I NEVER EXPECTED -- NEVER IN
MY LIFE TO LIVE THROUGH
SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
I NEVER IMAGINED THAT I WOULD
HAVE TO LIVE THROUGH SUCH PAIN.
>> Reporter: IT WAS JANUARY OF
2019 WHEN HERNANDEZ, A PUERTO
RICO RESIDENT, ARRIVED IN
GUADALAJARA, MEXICO, TO BEGIN
STUDYING TO BE A DOCTOR.
HE WAS 23.
>> I'D BEEN WORKING REALLY HARD
ALL MY LIFE TO MAKE THIS REAL
BECAUSE I HAD A DREAM TO START
IN MEDICINE.
>> Reporter: JUST TWO DAYS AFTER
HE ARRIVED, HE SAYS, HE WENT TO
TURN ON A BOILER IN ORDER TO GET
HOT WATER FOR HIS SHOWER.
THEN CAME THE EXPLOSION.
>> THE FLAMES WENT ALL OVER THE
APARTMENT AND THE BUILDING.
AND I HAD TO RUN THROUGH THE
FLAMES IN THE APARTMENT LOOKING
FOR A WAY OUT, AND THEN I ALMOST
LOST MY LIFE.
>> Reporter: RESCUERS SAVED HIM
AND TOOK HIM TO A MEXICAN
HOSPITAL, BUT HIS SEVERE BURN
INJURIES REQUIRED SPECIALIZED
CARE, SO AS A U.S. CITIZEN, HE
WAS THEN FLOWN TO ONE OF
AMERICA'S PREMIER BURN CENTERS,
THE U.S. ARMY'S INSTITUTE OF
SURGICAL RESEARCH IN SAN
ANTONIO.
KELLY BROWN WAS HIS PHYSICAL
THERAPY ASSISTANT.
>> HE HAD A HUGE PERCENTAGE OF
BURNS, ALMOST ALL OVER HIS BODY.
THERE WAS ONLY A FEW PLACES THAT
WEREN'T BURNED.
>> Reporter: HE WAS JUST IN AN
EXCRUCIATING AMOUNT OF PAIN.
>> YES.
YES, EVEN WITH PAIN MEDS BECAUSE
YOU CAN ONLY GIVE -- YOU CAN
ONLY GIVE SO MANY.
>> Reporter: ONE OF THE ONLY
PLACES NOT BURNED -- THE SOLES
OF HIS FEET.
RECOVERING MEANT 19 SURGERIES
AND HUNDREDS OF HOURS OF
PHYSICAL THERAPY.
>> I START FROM ZERO AGAIN.
I LEARN HOW TO WALK, HOW TO EAT,
HOW TO BREATHE, HOW TO SEE, HOW
TO DRESS MYSELF, HOW TO DO
EVERYTHING AGAIN.
>> HE'S A VERY DETERMINED YOUNG
MAN.
BUT HE'S BEEN THROUGH MORE PAIN
THAN ANY HUMAN SHOULD HAVE TO
DEAL WITH.
HE FOUGHT THROUGH IT.
HE ALWAYS WANTED TO GET BETTER,
AND HE WOULD ALWAYS GIVE IT HIS
BEST EFFORT AND THEN SOME.
>> Reporter: SOME SEVEN MONTHS
LATER, HERNANDEZ WALKED OUT OF
THE HOSPITAL.
[ CHEERS ]
THEN FLEW HOME TO PUERTO RICO.
>> THAT DAY WAS AMAZING.
[ CHANTS ]
TO SEE HOW HAPPY THEY WERE.
IT WAS A REALLY SPECIAL MOMENT
FOR ME.
>> Reporter: BUT WHEN HE GOT
HOME, HE FOUND HIS HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANY, INSURANCE
PROVIDED THROUGH HIS FATHER'S
JOB AS A POLICEMAN, HAD DENIED
PAYMENT FOR HIS MEDICAL
EXPENSES.
ALEXIS' FATHER SAYS THE COMPANY
NOW REFUSED TO PAY THE CLAIM,
TELLING HIM IT WAS BECAUSE THE
ACCIDENT TURRED IN MEXICO --
OCCURRED IN MEXICO.
THEN THE U.S. GOVERNMENT SENT
HIM THIS BILL SAYING FOR HIS
TREATMENT AT THAT MILITARY BURN
CENTER, HE OWED THE U.S.
TREASURY $1.7 MILLION.
AN AMOUNT THEY SUGGESTED HE
COULD PAY BY CHECK OR BY PHONE.
>> WHAT DID YOU THINK WHEN YOU
SAW THIS LETTER?
>> COMPLETELY -- COMPLETELY
HOPELESS.
>> Reporter: HIS LOCAL
REPRESENTATIVE SENT LETTERS TO
THE TREASURY, DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE, EVEN ATTORNY GENERAL
WILLIAM BARR LAST YEAR ASKING
THAT THE DEBT BE FORGIVEN.
THERE HAS BEEN NO RESPONSE.
SO HE'S TRYING TO MOVE ON
DESPITE OWING ALL THAT MONEY.
WHAT KEEPS DRIVING YOU FORWARD?
I MEAN, WHY ARE YOU SO
DETERMINED?
>> BECAUSE I GOT A SECOND
CHANCE.
I FEEL FORTUNATE.
I'M GRATEFUL THAT I CAN SEE THE
LIGHT OF THE DAY EVERY DAY.
NOT EVERYONE HAS A SECOND
CHANCE, AND I'M NOT GOING TO
WASTE IT.
>> Reporter: HE WANTS TO USE
THAT SECOND CHANCE, HE SAYS, TO
HELP OTHERS BY GOING BACK TO
MEDICAL SCHOOL AND FINALLY
BECOMING A DOCTOR IF THE DEBT
DOESN'T STAND IN HIS WAY.
>> I AM WORKING SO HARD TO GO
BACK TO SCHOOL.
AND MAYBE WITH THIS I'M NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO GO BACK.
>> Reporter: HERNANDEZ'S
INSURANCE COMPANY, FIRST
MEDICAL, WOULD NOT COMMENT TO US
DESPITE OUR MULTIPLE INQUIRIES.
WE ALSO REACHED OUT TO THE
DEPARTMENTS OF TREASURY,
DEFENSE, DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE,
NO COMMENT FROM ANY OF THEM
EITHER.
MEANWHILE, HERNANDEZ HAS HAD TWO
MORE SURGERIES SO FAR THIS YEAR.
HE STILL FACES MONTHS OF
ANTHONY, HIS FAMILY HAS BEEN
USING A GOFUNDME PAGE THAT WAS
SET UP FOR HIM TO PAY FOR A LOT
OF THESE EXPENSES.
BUT THE BILL STILL STANDS.
>> THAT'S 21 SURGERIES HE'S HAD
NOW.
THIS MAN, INCREDIBLE COURAGE AND
DETERMINATION.
I HOPE THIS GETS RESOLVED.
IT'S A RIDICULOUS SITUATION.
BUT WHAT HE'